okay so there has been this explosion of
controversy from Donald Trump calling
the mostly black city of Baltimore a
rodent infested mess that was somewhere
in those 30 or so tweets that Donald
Trump sent the Baltimore is two-thirds
black a 62 percent black 30% white he's
also talked about Elijah Cummings who is
the black congressman from Maryland so
let's look specifically now at the
Baltimore related tweets once again
Trump tweeting congressman Elijah
Cummings has been a brutal bully
shouting and screaming at the great men
and women of border patrol about
conditions at the southern border when
actually his Baltimore district is far
worse and more dangerous his district is
considered the worst in the USA as
proven last week during a congressional
tour the border is clean efficient and
well-run just very crowded Cummings
district is a disgusting rat and rodent
infested mess if he spent more time in
Baltimore maybe he could help clean up
this very dangerous and filthy place so
of course this is being called racist by
lots of people because it is hugely
racially tinged and it's tinged with
some of the same language that white
nationalists used and that anti-semites
and Nazis historically used about Jews
is it demonstrably actually racist I
mean yeah it probably is but I'm going
to make the case to you today that it
actually doesn't matter at this point
debating whether this is racist is a
loser's game in this particular case and
I think the left needs to understand
this going forward Republicans
immediately after Donald Trump was
accused of being racist for criticizing
Baltimore in this way Republicans
immediately pointed to Bernie Sanders
prior comments that Baltimore is a third
world country and a disgrace now the
context was totally different but it
immediately muddies the water did Bernie
mean that it's a third world country
because there's black people so yes this
infested stuff is the same language that
goes back to Nazi terminology about Jews
about Jews as an infestation like
roaches or vermin that needs to be
exterminated
it's the same
there's no doubt about it and of course
immediately the conversation becomes
about well Nancy Pelosi says it is
racist and Trump's talking not about
Baltimore itself or or Elijah Cummings
he's talking about the circumstances in
Baltimore and even Bernie has agreed
he's literally talking about rats he's
not saying black people or rats
he's saying there is a big rat problem
in Baltimore and you are actually racist
because you see Trump's comments as
racist you're the problem not us I do
not think that having another public
adjudication of if or how racist Trump's
comments are is going to help our
movement remove Donald Trump now there
will be some of the audience who
disagree with me and they will say we've
got to be calling this out I want to be
really clear here
I'm not saying Trump's comments aren't
racist they are hugely racially tinged
the language is language that we've seen
among racists for a very very long time
I'm not saying Trump doesn't have a lot
of racist supporters he obviously does
what I'm thinking out loud about here is
that I don't see the path between
another five days back and forth about
who thinks Trump's comment was racist
and who doesn't I don't see that as
being useful to the goal of removing
Donald Trump in 2020 and blinging
bringing some semblance of sanity back
to the United States because remember I
told you weeks ago this is now a
strategy lots of people are supporting
Trump because of comments like this this
is who they increasingly are publicly
Trump has emboldened them to publicly
say they support this language it's not
a liability for Trump's re-election for
him to use this language if Trump's
public racism isn't a liability then I
don't know what we gain by having these
incidents occupy five days in the media
of a debate over how racist was it at
the exclusion of reporting about all of
the terrible things that Donald Trump
and his administration are actually
doing I believe we are fomenting a
pointless cycle not one that isn't based
on fact okay I'm not defending the
comments for example though yesterday
morning Trump's chief of staff Mick
Mulvaney was on TV defending Donald
Trump's use of the word infested when
there are many more important things
that may
Mulvaney should be confronted about so
this is now a secondary news cycle to
take attention away from the immediate
crises that are going on the focus
should be it's beneath the office of the
president to insult cities and to insult
members of Congress and to talk in this
way period meanwhile the border is a
human rights Fiasco Trump is destroyed
alliances all over the world the White
House is now a laughingstock under Trump
were Americans we don't want to be a
laughingstock around the world and Trump
has failed to deliver basically every
campaign promise his supporters cannot
be reasoned with
and therefore a five-day debate over who
thinks the comments were racist how
racist was it what stupid ways can trump
is find to defend Trump is not going to
help us win in 2020 okay the constant
disarray and reaction to the content of
Trump's tweets lets him control the
story and the narrative there is a
narrative about the tweets that we need
to talk about it's that they are part of
the propaganda model that allows Donald
Trump to control the discussion that
should be our analysis and I'll be
talking about that later on today if you
disagree with my perspective on this let
me know I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and
the show is on Twitter at David Pakman
show today's program is sponsored in
part by a zip recruiter hiring people is
really difficult one of the things I do
here other than just hosting the show is
running the business side and that
includes hiring and Human Resources and
it takes a long time to find qualified
candidates it takes a long time to
screen applicants properly but there is
one place you can go where hiring is
simple fast and smart and it's a place
where growing businesses connect to
qualified candidates and that's zip
recruiter com slash Pakman zip recruiter
sends your job to over 100 of the web's
leading job boards but they don't stop
there they're powerful matching
technology will scan thousands of
resumes to find people with the right
experience and invite them to apply for
your job as the applications roll in zip
recruiter analyzes them spotlights the
top candidates so you never miss a great
match
and zip recruiter is so effective that
four out of five employers who post
unzip recruiter get a quality candidate
through the website within the first day
and right now our viewers and listeners
can try zip recruiter for free at this
exclusive web address zip recruiter
dot-com slash Pakman that's zip
recruiter dot-com slash PA que ma N one
more time
zip recruiter dot-com slash Pakman the
smartest way to hire